so working on a Horror history script
about a villain who has sparked a lot of
debate among fans with many people
taking this villain's side and saying
that this person was actually Justified
I'm not ready to say who that person is
yet but it got me thinking are there any
villains who were actually doing the
right thing so I put up a post asking my
audience for input challenging you guys
to name a villain who was in the right
and I also spent the day thinking about
it and basically decided uh no if they
were in the right then they wouldn't be
considered the villain right but after
mulling this over a little bit further I
do think that there may be a couple
villains who qualify to find out who
stick around to the end of this
[Music]
video so when I started thinking about
the villains that come to mind and
looking at some of the answers that you
guys provided I started seeing a few
Trends there were a few different
categories that all of these villains
seem to fall into but let's lay down the
technical definitions before continuing
so a villain is a character whose evil
actions or motives are important to the
plot the protagonist is just the leading
character in a work of fiction and the
antagonist opposes that leading
character usually the antagonist is the
villain but in some cases the
protagonist is the villain I went into
this video thinking that there wouldn't
be any examples of villains who I found
to have actions that were just but some
of these characters surprised me just as
you were probably surprised that I
finally uploaded something other than
Horror history also seeing as how this
isn't an episode of Horror history I
won't go too in depth into any of the
characters that I talk about here but
there may be spoilers for The Following
stories primarily Gone Girl and cabin in
the woods so with that out of the way
let's jump in to the first
category in my post there was one
character who was the overwhelming
favorite in the replies and that was
Carrie White from Stephen King's
car to which I have to say are you
kidding me Carrie White was not in the
right now I did kind of bait people by
putting her in the image but still the
fact that so many people chose her is
kind of concerning Carrie is a teenage
girl who is abused at home by her overly
religious mother while being bullied and
socially outcast at school by her cruel
classmates when Carrie hits puberty it
coincides with an Awakening of her
telekinetic power hour so when one of
her classmates orchestrates an extremely
cruel prank by dumping pigs blood on her
at the senior prom Carrie snaps kills
her classmates then Rampages into the
town and massacres it starting a huge
fire and telekinetically twisting the
fire hydrant lug nuts so tight that the
fire department could not access the
water now I'm not saying that Carrie is
pure evil and the people who bullied and
abused her are perfect angels they can
both be bad and they are but two wrongs
do not make it right if someone does
something to you and you do it back to
them you're now on the same level but
Carrie is even worse than that because
she not only got revenge on her iies but
also killed innocent people attacking
and self-defense is okay but that's not
what's going on here if we were to take
telekinetic abilities out of the
equation here for a moment this is
essentially a school shooting nobody is
out there saying that the Coline
Shooters did the right thing by shooting
up their school because they were
bullied so why are people saying that
about Carrie I'm guessing it's because
in the movie the story is told from
car's point of view we see the bullying
and I think it's normal to feel bad for
her I'm guessing a lot of people who
said Carrie have been bullied themselves
at some point and they were able to
share in her frustration and want to
protect her because they relate to her
in some small way and I think there's
just a little bit of a disconnect here I
can understand thinking that the
antagonist deserves some kind of
punishment and maybe some people got
that mixed up with saying that car was
in the right there were several answers
that I put under the same category of
they deserved it that amazing Amy Dunn
from Gone Girl staged her disappearance
to make it looked like her husband had
killed her to get back at him for his
infidelity but she also murders an
innocent guy who took her in another
example is Frankenstein's monster from
Mary Shell's Frankenstein the monster
was created by a scientist named Victor
Frankenstein obsessed with the idea of
creating life maybe just get a GF my guy
repulsed by his creation Victor abandons
the monster who then tries to connect
with other humans who were afraid of him
causing him to become bitter and violent
I think it's okay to feel bad for the
monster who didn't ask to be brought
into this world where he would be
rejected but I can't fully justify
hurting other people I would be more
willing to accept Frankenstein's monster
as a villain who was in the right rather
than Carri white because you could make
the argument that the monster didn't
know better but then you start getting
into the territory of maybe the monster
is not the villain maybe Victor
Frankenstein is the villain man who
tried to play God by creating life but
failed to take responsibility for what
he had created You could argue that
Victor Frankenstein was a villain who
was in the right that after all he was
just trying to advance Humanity through
science sure he made mistakes but it was
in the pursuit of knowledge if we
consider him to be the villain he would
fall into a different
[Music]
category Elijah price was a boy born
with a condition called osteogenesis imp
perfecta his bones were extremely
fragile so he spent most of his life
broken and in wheelchairs me Mr glass
while he was physically very fragile he
was extremely gifted from a mental
standpoint he theorized that if someone
like him exists on one end of the
spectrum there must be a hero who is
incredibly durable on the other end he
carries out a series of terrorist
attacks in search of this person
eventually finding a man named David
Dunn who is the only Survivor of a train
wreck caused by Mr glass he spends the
rest of the story encouraging David to
take on the role of a superhero when one
of you guys suggested him as a villain
who was in the right it was because he
made sacrifices with a noble goal and
discovered an actual superhero who would
go on to protect the city the villains
in this category mostly all fall under
the same moral dilemma it's basically a
more complicated version of the infamous
trolley problem if five people are tied
to one side of the track and one person
is tied to the other is it okay to pull
the lever and kill the one person in
order to save the five according to talk
resource.com about 90% of people would
pull the lever and kill the one person
to save the five so that settles it Mr
glass was in the right right actually
allow me to correct you the trolley
problem only has two options pulled
lever or don't well I always like to say
that you could pull it at the merge
point and derail the trolley depends if
anyone's on the trolley and how fast
it's going but my point is if I were in
Mr glass's position and I believe there
was a superhero out there who needed to
be discovered I wouldn't settle for a
plan that involved killing other people
he could have just gotten involved in
contacting survivors of the many
accidents that already happened or just
held some kind of amateur sports
tournament there are definitely less
evil ways he could have gone about it
but he essentially wanted to be the
villain because in his comic books the
hero and the villain are oppos opposites
in almost every way Mr glass wasn't in
the right but I think we are getting
closer our next villain also took up the
Diabolical Podium out of what he saw as
necessity but the stakes were much
higher Louch lamperouge from code guas
wanted to overthrow the oppressive
britanian Empire but makes many morally
questionable sacrifices to do it
including controlling others committing
acts of terrorism and be betraying his
friends what do you mean there's only
soup it means there's only soup well
then get out of this soup aisle all
right you don't have to shout at me I
love how there going to be people who
watch this video who have never seen
code gios and now they think that those
are their actual voices what do you mean
you're at sou a couple of you brought up
Joseph seed from Far Cry 5 Joseph was
essentially a cult leader who believes
that he was chosen by God to gather
followers and lead them to Eden's gates
to protect them from the incoming
apocalypse however he's willing to use
violence and torture to advance his
goals at one point he pinches es the
tube on his own daughter's life support
to kill her and prove his Devotion to
God under normal circumstances he'd just
be seen as your run-of-the-mill
religious extremist no better than some
of the worst terrorists of our world
however in the end the apocalypse
actually happens just as he predicted
down to the very moment making it seem
as if Joseph really was receiving the
word of God given that information it's
hard to say that he wasn't in the right
any of the evil actions that he took
before this point don't really matter
everyone who wasn't a follower of his
would be wiped out anyway so the guy did
what he had to do to save Humanity
the story has an interesting message
because the religious extremists of our
world probably do believe that they're
serving God and do see their evil
actions as heroic I think Joseph seed
forces the audience to see the world
through their eyes how do you deal with
these people when they see themselves as
Divine it's an interesting quandry
disclaimer although I do think Joseph is
one of the best examples of a righteous
villain I am not condoning any kind of
religious violence I don't want to see
any news articles about the CES World
pipeline okay the world of superheroes
offers a couple other examples of
villains in this category Poison Ivy
from Batman man engages in Acts of
Terror in defense of the environment
Thanos partook in what amounts to a mass
genocide by snapping away half of all
life in the universe which he sees as a
virtuous act to curb overpopulation and
reduce strain on the world's resources I
hope I got that right I'm not actually
in the no when it comes to the world of
Marvel but I do know a little bit about
Thanos just by being so into internet
culture I mean the Thanos caring
hilarious at man's plan to defeat Thanos
one of the best things I've ever seen
now when I was making my list there were
some characters that I ended up moving
into a subcategory they weren't just
sacrificing Justice in the name of
something they believe in they were
taking Justice into their own hands
these are the
[Applause]
vigilantes in the series known as Death
Note Light Yagami was a high school
student who happened to p a notebook
that had the power to kill anyone whose
name is written into it after testing it
on a criminal who had taken hostages
he's horrified by its power and resolves
to get rid of it but then he has another
idea light is going to use the notebook
to take out all of the world's criminals
so that only the good remain he wants to
create a new world a Utopia with no bad
people or crime this approach is popular
and light or as he becomes known K
amasses followers all over the world who
realize that someone is dishing out
punishment to criminals and supports his
Endeavor others see him as just as bad
or worse than those he is killing and
seek to hunt down and arrest this new
serial killer the debate in the series
has extended to real life with fans
arguing over whether light was a good
guy or a bad guy non-stop in the 20
years since the series came out as a fan
I spent a lot of time thinking about
this series so it's easy for me to see
that while light has good intentions it
is evil for any one man to be judge jury
and executioner the legal system has
split up these roles for a reason having
one person handle all three is too much
power and that leads to corruption which
is exactly what happens to life one
person's judgment can never be unbiased
and may not always be fair vigilante
justice stories are something of a genre
of their own Billy from Silent Night
deadly night similarly targeted those
who were naughty Before Christmas Clyde
Shelton from law-abiding citizen took
Revenge on done corrupt police officers
and criminals who were involved in the
Miss sentencing of a man who killed his
wife and daughter similarly Dexter
Morgan from the TV series Dexter was a
forensic specialist by day and serial
killer by night only going after heinous
criminals who had escaped the legal
system then there's John Kramer or as
he's more commonly known jigsaw from the
saw franchise who subjected his targets
to agonizing torture devices which he
believed would reinvigorate those who
had lost their appreciation for Life
assuming they survived don't worry the
video is not over perhaps the best
example in the wider made SA sacrifices
for the greater good genre would be the
director from The Cabin in the Woods the
head of a secret organization whose goal
is to sacrifice five human archetypes to
arace of ancient gods living underground
in order to entertain them and satisfy a
ritual if the ritual fails the ancient
ones will rise up and destroy the Earth
so the organization puts a lot of
resources into creating monsters capable
of terrorizing and killing the young
subjects it's hard to argue against what
the director and the rest of the
organization are doing here because
they're literally saving the world the
only way they know how however they may
also fall into another
[Music]
category one of the top answers to my
query outside of Carri white which
occupied the top three spots was Parker
crane also known as the bride and black
from
Insidious as a boy Parker was abused by
his mother Michelle who forced him to
dress up like a girl because she didn't
like him going by the name that his
father gave him that is not your
name
Parker is not your name that is the name
name your father gave you your
name is maryn what's the clinical name
for this type of behavior oh yeah she
kind of cray cray in life she forced
Parker to do horrible things basically
molding him into a serial killer if she
sees you she'll make me kill you even
after she died she continued to
manipulate him from the afterlife realm
known as the further after she's
eradicated from the further Parker
basically just Fades away Parker did do
evil things but he was controlled from
such a young age and the grip was kept
on him for so long that it almost seems
like it was unavoidable you could make
the argument that Michelle is the main
villain here and I would agree with that
but Parker is technically a villain as
well as per our definition I also have a
special spot for Parker because my black
bride video was the one where I did the
fake brand deal for tap water which is
one of the dumbest gags that I've ever
done make sure to use the code cz's
world when purchasing tap water so they
know that we sent you you can just say
it out loud whenever you turn on the
faucet and as much fun as that was it
didn't exactly pay the bills so
hopefully this does we got an ey
[Music]
break Jack Torrance is the main
antagonist from the shiny Jack is a
teacher and father asked to take the job
of the winter caretaker at the Overlook
Hotel but the Overlook Hotel is haunted
and Jack is possessed to go crazy and
try to kill his
family here's Cy I actually said that at
a Halloween party this year after
showing up dressed like this note you
could make the argument for both
versions but the book version gives a
heavier implication that Jack was
possessed when Danny has his final
confrontation with him he seems to
realize this and says you're it not my
daddy you're the hotel and when you get
what you want you won't give my daddy
anything because you're selfish and
after Jack regains control momentarily
he tells Dany to run away somebody in
the comments had another suggestion I'm
going to skip the obvious ones and say
the mom from The bobad Duck they did way
too good a job of making that kid the
whiniest and most unbearable child sorry
but I can't blame her reaction for most
of the movie it's a pretty funny comment
because he's framing it to fit into the
they deserved it
category which may be
deserved but realistically we also got
to consider the puppet villain
category Amelia the mother in The Baba
is entranced to kill her dog and nearly
her son when she's possessed by this
monster from her child's bedtime story
this one is going to open up an
interesting can of worms or perhaps I
should say bowl of worms because the
monster is a metaphor for her grief and
depression which she's unable to get
under control so on on one hand she
can't use the puppet excuse all of her
actions are actually coming from her she
didn't get a handle on her grief so it's
her fault however you could make the
argument that she's just a victim of the
circumstances yes she's mentally ill but
it largely stems from her husband's
Unexpected death she didn't ask for any
of it is it really her fault that she's
struggling personally I think you have
to hold her accountable for what she did
if you give a pass to everyone who does
something bad and blames it on mental
illness then every criminal is going to
use that excuse in fact you already see
that happening it seems like every
apology video These Days pulls the
mental illness car now that's not to say
that those people don't deal with mental
health problems and I'm not trying to
say that this isn't an issue but think
about it like this there are plenty of
people with grief and depression who
don't try to kill their dog and son if
you have mental issues that you feel are
controlling your behavior it should be
your responsibility to get a hold of it
if you touch my son again I'll [__]
kill you but when it comes to puppet
villains it doesn't always have to be a
supernatural Puppeteer take stumacher
from screen he was roped into a murder
scheme when his high school friend tried
to get revenge on his father father's
adulterous mistress and her daughter
what's your motive peer pressure I'm far
too sensitive but none of the puppet
villain answers were upvoted as much as
this one Jaws he was just living his
best life and doing what sharks do true
true boys got to eat that's our next
[Music]
category we all know who Jaws is right
do I have to explain that one he's a
shark that ate some people this is
actually the answer that inspired me to
create the different categories for this
video that and the fact that I crave
structure in my life and in my videos
there are plenty of examples like this
many of them are other animals who are
just naturally hunting to survive I
think someone said the indoraptor from
Jurassic World Jurassic boys Jurassic
boys I will also add the Velociraptors
from velocci coaster I know there's
going to be some vegan out there who's
like actually allow me to correct you
but these guys are carnivores they have
to eat me to survive although the vegan
Velociraptor does sound like a funny
comedy sketch it's not just animals
though several horror movie villains
that I've talked about are deities
someone mentioned Sam from trick-or
treat he's just the enforcer of what Man
created Sam is basically a Halloween
spirit who punishes those who do not
adhere to the ancient traditions of the
holiday sin Sam ha which was the
precursor to our Halloween speaking of
people who deserved it this character
named Emma tries to take the Halloween
decorations down on the night of then
says this they hate Halloween nobody
could possibly be considered in the
wrong for murdering this [__] similar
to Sam and also made by the same
director we have Kampus instead of
enforcing traditions of Celtic folklore
Kampus hails from Alpine and Nordic
Legends and protects the ancient
Traditions around Christmas someone on
threads mentioned the killer clowns from
outer space arguing that we eat things
that are less intelligent than we are so
why shouldn't they true true but on
closer inspection I'm not sure if we
should trust this guy because he appears
to be a killer clown from outer space
himself he might be trying to get us to
accept Our Fate as cotton candy treats
another one I thought of was death from
Final Destination You could argue that
death is not an entity more so a concept
or force of nature but death is the
closest thing we have to a villain in
most of those movies each Final
Destination film features a character
who has a clairvoyant Vision allowing
the character to save his or herself and
several others from a horrible disaster
but because they were supposed to die
that day death keeps coming for them and
they have to figure out how before
it's too late I have one more example
and while it's not the perfect case for
virtuous villainy it's Unique enough to
go in a category all on its
own Midsummer is the 2019 folk horror
film directed by Ari Aster at the
beginning of the movie the protagonist
Danny arter loses her parents and sister
in a horrible tragedy and 6 months later
her boyfriend invites her to go on a
trip to Sweden to experience the
midsummer festival at the home Village
of his friend pel pel is immediately
interested in Dany coming with you know
I'm very very glad you're coming I think
it's very good you're coming once there
he teaches Danny about how in their
culture everything is experienced
together including emotions like joy and
Sara the reason he was excited to have
her on the trip is because she's been
grieving the loss of her family and his
family can help her bear the weight of
that emotional burden the American
visitors are shocked and disgusted when
they witnessed the atesa a ritual
suicide committed by The Village Elders
after reaching age 72 but in their
culture this is normal and it's
considered an honor because the elders
know that they'll never grow old enough
to where caring for them becomes a
burden in the end each of the foreign
visitors other than Dany break one of
the Cults rules and are offered up as a
part of the sacrifice at the end of the
midsummer celebration while Dany becomes
their May Queen and joins the we learned
that pel was planning it from the
beginning their life cycle is broken up
into seasons and those aged 18 to 36 are
sent on a pilgrimage to meet people
outside the family and bring them back
for the purposes of reproduction with
genetic variation and of course to serve
as fresh blood sacrifices during the
burning ritual while the international
guests were Disturbed and off-put seeing
ritual suicide that they weren't used to
the cult members seem okay with it
there's a whole other debate to be had
about the ethics of Youth in Asia it's
mostly frowned upon throughout the world
today but there are major Nations where
it's legal like Belgium Lux Berg Canada
New Zealand Spain the Netherlands and
Colombia it's a compelling debate that
I'd be interested to learn more about a
lot of people online seem to support the
idea but obviously some are against any
form of taking human life it reminds me
of the abortion debate only it takes
place on the other end of your life but
even if we ignore this particular issue
I can't say that pel was in the right
here it's one thing to sacrifice
yourself if your culture is accepting of
it he lost me when he sacrificed his
friends who didn't know what they were
getting themselves into pel is
definitely in the wrong on this one also
their family intentionally inbreeds one
person who they refer to as their Oracle
because they claim that the mental
deformities give him Vision that is not
clouded by normal cognition you're
intentionally giving someone a lifetime
of medical problems that's totally
[__] up but despite those issues I
think they were only bad to us is an
interesting category even though I could
only think of one example and that one
example doesn't exactly qualify if you
can think of any others let me know in
the comments I think the takeaway here
is that most villains aren't perfect
angels and if they were they wouldn't
really be villains would they but the
best ones the ones that are the most fun
to to talk about are the ones that have
people on both sides of the aisle the
ones where you can have a discussion
that turns into a discussion of Ethics a
lot of YouTubers like to say okay let's
keep it civil in the comments but
honestly I kind of don't care feel free
to rip each other apart in the comments
but in my opinion it isn't actually that
relevant if the person is actually in
the right or in the wrong it is those
who think they are in the right or at
the very least understand why they are
in the wrong and still see it fit to
just push on anyway who make the most
compelling and memorable villains okay I
was about to finish the video but we've
got a late sub mission in the 11th Hour
the blind guy from don't breathe girl
girl do you not remember the second half
of that movie but if you want to
understand these morally ambiguous
malactor on a deeper level then you're
in luck because I've already done Deep
dive analyses on many of them in my
amazing and wonderful show called Horror
history you'll find a playlist of
everyone I talked about today on the
left if you love analyzing evil doers as
much as I do make sure you subscribe to
C's world for new Horrors every week
ring the death bell and select all
notifications and I will see you in the
next one assuming we both survive okay
now it really is
over